débuter notre commission de
ce matin monsieur le Président votre
dernière visite devant notre commission
en tout cas dans cette configuration
date du 3 octobre 2018 je crois que vous
êtes intervenus depuis dans une table
ronde c'était juste quelques mois après
votre nomination au poste de président
de l'AFP
c'est peut dire que depuis le monde a
changé enfin le contexte a changé votre
mandat mais je n'y vois aucun lien a été
marqué par un mouvement de contestation
sociale sans précédent une crise
sanitaire mondiale et depuis quelques
mois un conflit armé sans équivalent en
Europe depuis la fin de la Seconde
Guerre mondiale surtout ces sujets il a
été nécessaire de livrer au public une
information
fiable objectif et professionnel à
l'heure où celle-ci est bien trop
souvent traitée de manière imprécise
orientée et parfois sans nuance durant
ces cinq années votre agence a dû faire
face simultanément à une actualité très
riche à de lourdes filles économiques
qui a d'importantes problématiques de
gestion interne dont vous nous aviez
longuement parlé en 2018 votre premier
mandat donc été celui des obstacles et
des réformes les deux étant parfois liés
du reste notamment le développement du
rôle de l'agence en matière de vidéo sur
lequel vous aviez beaucoup insisté aussi
je dis bien premier mandat car vous avez
été largement désigné par un pour un
nouveau mandat le 10 novembre dernier
par votre conseil d'administration notre
rapporteur des crédits pour la presse
Michel Laugier qui suit au plus près la
situation de l'AFP c'est c'était livré
dans son avis sur le projet de loi de
finance pour 2023 une évaluation très
positive de votre action et avec celle à
lui votre réussite dans le redressement
de l'agence rassurez-vous nous ne disons
pas ça à tous nos invités
les défis ne manqueront pas cependant
pour vous dans les mois à venir je pense
en particulier sur le plan économique
aux conséquences de l'inflation qui n'a
pas été pleinement prise en compte dans
votre dotation annuelle et puis bien sûr
au flot de fausses informations qui
continuent d'irriguer une partie des
débats publics
et à l'état préoccupant de la presse en
général votre principal client
historique surtout ces sujets nous
serions heureux de vous entendre
pour faire un point sur la situation de
votre vision du secteur je vous propose
dans un premier temps de nous présenter
votre action au cours de ces années
écoulées et vous ambitions bien sûr pour
les années à venir je passerai ensuite
ta parole à Michel Laugier pour une
première série de questions et puis bien
sûr chacune des sénatrices et sénateurs
qui le souhaiteront pourront également
vous interroger je vous laisse la parole
se poser là merci monsieur le président
[Musique]
et merci pour vos aimables à l'adresse
de l'AFP je suis venu seul mais je
travaille avec une équipe de grande
qualité et c'est compliments s'adressent
je pense à tous les salariés de l'AFP
qui ont fait des efforts considérables
ces dernières années on démenti le
cliché
tenace d'une agence difficile à bouger
bien au contraire l'agence s'est
transformé ces dernières années
la traduction en est un redressement
financier indéniable
j'étais venu en effet en 2018 la
situation c'était une
un effet ciseaux sur les revenus et les
charges absolument symétriques puisque
les entre 2014 et 2017
les revenus avaient chuté de près de 4%
et les charges avaient augmenté de 4%.
donc
conséquence logique la maison avait
cumulé des pertes de l'ordre de 20
millions d'euros sur cette période
j'ai vu que le
titre de cette audition que vous avez
choisi était AFP lors de la reconquête
avec un point d'interrogation je ne sais
pas si on est en mode reconquête mais on
a été en mode Conquête certainement ces
dernières années
d'abord sur la vidéo comme vous l'avez
dit j'en avais fait la seule priorité du
premier mandat
2018-2023
je m'inscrivais dans les pas de mes
prédécesseurs qui avait commencé de
développer cette activité sur laquelle
l'AFP était de toute évidence en retard
par rapport à ces deux grands
concurrents Reuters et la société de
presse et le projet avait été de
développer puisqu'il fallait quantifier
cet objectif 23 millions de revenus
additionnels
sur les nouveaux métiers de l'image en
l'espace de 5 ans je pense que c'est un
objectif il sera mesuré à la fin de
l'année mais que nous que nous
atteindrons en dépit du covid qui a
quand même bien ralenti l'activité donc
c'était un je pense un choix en tout cas
qui était qui était juste nous avons
maintenant un produit vidéo qui est
aussi au moins aussi bon que celui des
meilleurs agences et nous nous gagnons
des parts de marché continuellement sur
sur elle ce qui me laisse penser qu'on a
été effectivement en mode Conquête autre
mode Conquête ça a été le développement
d'une toute nouvelle activité qui est ce
qu'on appelle le fake checking à
l'agence on appelle ça l'investigation
numérique d'abord parce qu'on n'aime pas
les termes anglo-saxons et ensuite parce
que ça nous paraît correspond davantage
à la réalité du travail journalistique
est un vrai travail d'enquête en
utilisant des des logiciel souvent de
vérifications et en travaillant sur les
contenus qui sont publiés sur les
plateformes et nous avons bâti en
l'espace de 5 ans le plus grand réseau
au monde de lutte contre la
désinformation
ce faisant nous avons développé aussi de
nouveaux clients et je pense que le
meilleur indicateur de la transformation
de l'AFP c'est 5 dernières années ça a
été le fait qu'aujourd'hui
nous faisons à peu près 10% de notre
chiffre d'affaires avec les plateformes
que ce soit via l'investigation
numérique ou que ce soit via les accords
de droits voisins pour lesquels je
renouvelle mes remerciements à la
représentation nationale pour son appui
décisif ses clients ne figuraient tout
simplement pas au rang de des nôtres
quand je suis arrivé à l'agence donc
nous avons maintenant avec méta avec
Google avec Tik Tok des clients nouveaux
qui transforment un peu le visage de
l'agence
ces trois éléments nous ont permis de
retrouver de la croissance qui était à
la fois le plus difficile et le plus
nécessaire
l'an dernier nous avons fait 5% de
croissance cette année on devrait faire
en 2022 pas loin de 6 %
et nous avons réussi notre plan de
d'économie qui prévoyait de dégager par
rapport à 2018 en 2023 à peu près 19
millions d'économies
nous l'avons fait tout en augmentant le
nombre de journalistes dans la maison
puisque en gros grâce notamment
l'investigation numérique
les effectifs de journalistes vont
augmenter de 70 à 80 personnes d'ici la
fin de l'année
nous avons
fait un plan d'économie assez habituel
sur sur l'immobilier sur les achats et
nous avons profité d'un plan de départ
qui était très attendu en 2019 et qui a
porté surtout sur les fonctions support
voilà ça c'est le c'est le passé qui
nous rend
assez fier oui du travail effectué et
mais qui ne nous fait pas plonger je
vous rassure dans une espèce d'extra
d'exubérance et rationnelle on reste
calme d'autant que on a des gros défis
face à nous vous les avez mentionnés moi
ma grande préoccupation c'est que
l'inflation ne vienne pas manger tous
les efforts qui ont été faits ces
dernières années
or
l'inflation je vous rappelle nous sommes
une agence mondiale et donc on a on fait
face à des situations absolument
dramatiques dans certains pays on parle
beaucoup de la Turquie aujourd'hui on
parle beaucoup de la Russie on parle
aussi de l'Angleterre des États-Unis
tous ces pays
nous avons des négociations difficiles
et on doit est d'autant plus difficile
que les salaires ont été très contraints
ces dernières années et que sur fond de
bons résultats qu'on n'a pas caché
naturellement salariés
les revendications sont fortes donc
c'est ça le défi numéro un nous avons
déjà consenti un certain nombre
d'efforts qui étaient nécessaires qui
vont représenter grosso modo si j'ajoute
les mesures que nous avons prises plus
l'effet de l'inflation sur nos propres
coûts transports fluide etc on a à peu
près 5 millions de de surcoût par
rapport aux traines habituelles en 2023
par rapport à 2021
et puis arrive aussi d'autres
choses plus il y a des facteurs assez
structurels qui font qu'on doit rester
très vigilant alors il y en a que vous
connaissez bien que le monsieur logis a
bien documenté qui est la crise de la
presse sur fond dans voler des cours du
papier je crois que vous me souviens que
vous aviez parlé pour la France d'un
chiffre de 175 millions de surcoût je
vous rappelle que nous nous avons des
clients en France il y a beaucoup
d'aides à la presse nous avons des
clients presse ça représente encore un
quart de notre base client partout dans
le monde et vous imaginez que en
Amérique latine au Moyen-Orient
en Asie il y a pas les mêmes systèmes
d'aide donc on s'attend un peu un bain
de sang qui a commencé et ça va ça va
naturellement affecter notre chiffre
d'affaires et puis il y a un autre
facteur qui est un peu le signe noir
auquel on s'attendait vraiment pas qui
est la crise de la tech je vous ai dit
qu'on avait une à peu près
10% maintenant même un peu plus de notre
chiffre d'affaires qui était réalisé
avec le plateformes on avait de bonnes
perspectives de développement puis
surviennent ce que vous savez le chaos
chez Twitter qui était un client
important comment ça se traduit pour
l'AFP bah tout simplement nous n'avons
plus d'interlocuteurs nous ne sommes
plus payés
très difficile de se développer avec un
client pareil TikTok en grand désarroi
meta
annonce vouloir se retirer des news et à
commencer à supprimer un contrat que
nous avions avec eux donc
il se ressentent comme vous le savez sur
le la lutte avec Tik Tok donc sur les
vidéos de divertissement de cours format
et sur le métaverse donc ce sont des
facteurs de un peu d'inquiétude et par
ailleurs je pense que
[Musique]
si on peut être fier du chemin accompli
je pense qu'on a fait le plus facile
maintenant on doit chaque année du fait
que 75% de nos dépenses sont des
dépenses de personnel et qui a en gros
on prend 3 millions d'euros de coûts
supplémentaires chaque année du fait des
mécanismes automatiques donc il faut
chaque année qu'on trouve 3 millions
d'économies pour compenser ça
et par ailleurs on est exposé à trois
quarts de notre revenu un marché des
médias qui est quand même pas hyper
dynamique donc tout ça fait que c'est
difficile et les leviers d'amélioration
deviennent de plus en plus difficiles à
chercher avec un retour sur
investissement qui est il existe je vous
rassure mais c'est
quand on fait comme on l'a fait ces
dernières années une rationalisation
immobilière en arrêtant la location d'un
bâtiment de 3000 m² en regroupant tout
le monde dans un même bâtiment vous avez
3 millions d'économies qui vous tombent
tout cru je dis pas que c'est facile
mais c'est maîtrisable quand on fait un
plan de départ volontaire là aussi c'est
assez cadré l'exercice est connu vous
pouvez le chiffrer ça va là on est sur
des sujets beaucoup plus difficiles on
s'attaque à l'organisation
ça c'est difficile mais ça n'en est
naturellement que plus stimulant voilà
donc c'est un peu le
l'atmosphère enfin l'état d'esprit à
l'agence est un mélange de confiance
de satisfaction sur le chemin accompli
mais pas pas non plus
d'auto-satisfaction voilà et je dirais
de grandes vigilance sur la suite et je
vous dis moi mon obsession c'est que
je le dis très simplement on n'est pas
relancé dans dans trois ans un plan de
départ parce que on a lâché les vannes
ouvert les vannes pour satisfaire des
revendications salariales parfaitement
légitimes au passage donc on essaye de
de faire au mieux c'est pas simple
mais c'est le grand sujet du moment
pour pour l'avenir mais je crois qu'on
va passer aux questions pour l'avenir
moi j'ai proposé au conseil
d'administration une nouvelle stratégie
on est en 2023 dans une année de
transition puisque c'est la dernière
année du contrat d'objectif et de moyens
en gros on a déjà en février 2023
réalisé à peu près à 95% tous les
objectifs donc on est assez confiant
qu'on sera au rendez-vous mais on
prépare déjà le suivant
et
j'ai proposé au Conseil une une
stratégie qui
ne porte plus sur la vidéo puisque je
vous ai dit on est maintenant
tout à fait à niveau et même bon comment
on gagne des parts de marché je pense
qu'on a un produit qui est qui parfois
est supérieur je pourrais vous expliquer
pourquoi ensuite et la stratégie est
très simple c'est
de devenir
l'agence préférée des médias partout
dans le monde
l'agence dont ils ne peuvent pas se
passer
alors ça c'est un peu ça peut paraître
un peu un slogan on va naturellement
quantifier
cette cet objectif
l'idée qui est derrière c'est que du
fait de la crise des médias
beaucoup de petits médias déjà n'ont
plus que comme fournisseur de
d'informations brutes qu'une agence
depuis longtemps et les grands médias de
plus en plus qui auparavant étaient
abonnés aux trois grandes agences
mondiales je mets de côté Bloomberg est
très spécialisé
de plus en plus il passe à deux flux
puis et puis ils vont finir par passer à
un flux France Télévisions n'a plus
qu'un seul fournisseur
la BBC on a plus que deux et bien nous
devons dans ce marché qui tend vers un
modèle de fournisseur unique être
l'agence de dernier ressort celle qui
est indispensable par sa couverture dont
on ne peut pas se passer
c'est ça le l'objectif que nous devons
nous fixer pour les 5 ans à venir au
service de nos clients premiers qui sont
les médias encore 75% de notre
portefeuille il y a deux sous objectifs
de rangs qui sont aussi des priorités
stratégiques mais je dirais de rang 2
un de ces objectifs c'est de consolider
notre leadership dans la lutte contre la
désinformation et encore beaucoup pas
faire c'est une activité qui est récente
qui a trois ans on a maintenant à peu
près pas loin de 150 facts shaker ce qui
a plein temps travail dans 80 pays dans
24 langues pour contrôler ce qui se
passe sur les réseaux sociaux
il y a d'autres acteurs qui viennent
dans la course et on peut encore
développer cette activité en dépit de la
crise de la tech dont je vous ai parlé
et l'autre objectif c'est de diversifier
un peu notre chiffre d'affaires parce
que être exposé à hauteur de trois
quarts de son chiffre d'affaires à des
marchés des médias qui est pas ultra
dynamique c'est pas très bon même si ce
sont nos clients premiers il faut qu'on
développe davantage le les courants
d'affaires avec les autres catégories de
clients les plateformes les entreprises
les fondations et on a un plan de
bataille pour cela mais encore une fois
le l'objectif premier qui doit tirer moi
j'essaye de
[Musique]
moi de donner des leçons de management
mais je la seule chose que j'ai retenue
je crois qu'en terme de stratégie c'est
que d'abord il est tout aussi important
de dire ce qu'on ne va pas faire que ce
qu'on va faire donc par exemple pour
l'AFP il y avait des débats sans fin sur
est-ce qu'il faut avoir une stratégie
comment on dit bitoussi de communication
consommateur la réponse est clairement
NON et ne passons pas de temps là-dessus
et aussi quand on fixe des objectifs et
on n'est pas trop nombreux donc il y en
avait un pour 2018-2023 et que cet
objectif soit simple à comprendre donc
c'était développer la vidéo avec 23
millions d'euros de chiffre d'affaires
supplémentaires pour la période passée
maintenant c'est devenir l'agence
préférée des médias et celle dont il ne
peuvent se passer
merci pour ce propos liminaire qui est
très clair sans plus tarder jeunes la
parole à Michel loger pour une première
série de questions merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Président de l'AFP
vous avez auditionné 11 octobre dernier
et vous aviez alors très franchement
indiqué votre souhait de repartir pour 5
années supplémentaires
et tout aussi franchement j'ai apporté
mon soutien voilà dont je voudrais
aujourd'hui
l'occasion de mes données de vous
féliciter de vive voix pour votre
nomination encore pour 5 ans
trois questions ou trois thèmes à
aborder mais vous avez déjà développé
pas mal le futur contrat d'objectifs et
de moyens
vous avez présenté ça devant le conseil
d'administration déjà quelques
orientations mais où en sont vos
négociations et votre tutelle parce que
c'est bien d'avoir des projets parce que
la tutelle aussi vous suit à ce niveau
là et qu'elles sont donc les premiers
retours
de très nombreux cas de violence à
l'encontre des journalistes ont été
enregistrés ces dernières années la
guerre à l'Ukraine a marqué
n'étouffement de la presse en Russie
sans précédent et comme a pu en
témoigner directement devant le
président de Laura Lafont devant Max
Brisson et devant Julien barjetton et
moi-même le prix Nobel de la Paix 2021
Dimitri nous a off que nous avons reçu
ici exceptionnellement au Sénat comme
président d'une des trois grandes
agences de presse au monde comment
jugez-vous la situation
et puis vous l'avez aussi évoqué les
droits voisins donc vous avez jugé tout
à fait satisfaisante donc votre
collaboration avec Google l'accord que
vous avez signé vous avez toujours pas
réglé le montant de cet accord mais bon
sur les négociations avec Facebook et
les autres médias et surtout
travaillez-vous de concert avec la
Fédération française des agences de
presse pour parvenir à une solution pour
l'ensemble de la profession merci je
vais donner aussi la parole à Céline
Boulley qui membre du Conseil supérieur
de l'est absolument j'ai la joie et
l'honneur d'icié depuis un certain
nombre de temps et par conséquent je
connais assez bien je crois la situation
de l'agence et permettez-moi de vous
féliciter de me rejoindre mon collègue
pour dire la satisfaction qui est la
nôtre d'avoir vu les défis que vous avez
à relever qui n'était pas moindres qui
n'était pas petit au moment où vous êtes
arrivés à la tête de l'agence et le
rapport annuel qui a été nous a été
remis et rédigée par Christine concert
d’état la tête du Conseil supérieur à
bien conclu au fait que vous aviez
relevé les défis alors je vais pas tous
les rappeler vous les avez effleurées en
terme de personnel en termes
d'immobilier même il était question de
savoir si l'agence allait rester dans
son lieu historique et ça ça a été
particulièrement bien géré au moment où
d'ailleurs où la crise covid arrivait et
ce n'était pas le moindre des défis moi
je voulais simplement que vous puissiez
développer un petit peu plus votre point
fort aujourd'hui qui est effectivement
le fac checking vous en avez parlé un
petit peu puisque vous êtes devenu
leader mondiaux en français donc
investigation numérique on aime bien
quand même parler français au sein de
cette commission
on a fait hier une réunion avec Tik Tok
qui nous a dit qu'ils avaient signé un
contrat avec vous pour le fac checking
dans en vue de protéger les jeunes
publics mais on a l'impression que c'est
un peu comment dirais-je cette histoire
de fack checking que vous voulez
développer à juste titre c'est un peu
vider l'océan avec une cuillère les
défis sont extrêmement importants
dans cette matière et votre place va
être cruciale à l'avenir et deuxièmement
pour le développement de la vidéo qui a
été votre premier combat
quand vous êtes arrivés à la tête de
l'agence si vous pouviez nous dire
comment vous comptez gagner plus de part
de marché en vidéo à l'avenir parce que
c'est un enjeu très important et que ce
soit le fac checking ou la vidéo sont
des enjeux financiers aussi pour
compenser les pertes liées à la presse
écrite je crois que le Fat checking vous
votre objectif c'est 8 millions d'euros
voilà si vous pouviez nous en dire un
petit peu plus là dessus merci beaucoup
vous laissez répondre à ces deux
premiers intervenants alors relation
avec la tutelle sur le com les
discussions commencent
les ministères les trois grands
ministères concernés culture à faire
étrangères et budget sont naturellement
représentés au conseil d'administration
et je pense que
il n'y a pas de il y a plutôt une une
adhésion à la stratégie présentée
maintenant le tout le travail consiste à
la décliner en chiffres et l'éléphant
dans la pièce c'est naturellement quel
sera le montant du soutien de l'État
pour la période d'avenir voilà nous nous
plaidons je n'aurai sans doute pas dit
ça il y a un an à la même époque mais du
fait de ce qui s'est passé depuis un an
nous plaidons pour un ajustement en
raison de l'inflation
on verra ce qu'il en résultera en
parallèle nous avons notifié à la
Commission européenne le service
d'intérêt économique d'intérêt général
comme nous devions le faire et donc la
Commission doit j'espère d'ici la fin de
l'année se prononcer sur la validité de
ce régime dette d'État qui a été défini
en 2014 et il était prévu que 10 ans
après il soit revu
dans la mesure où l'AFP a montré qu'elle
savait faire aussi l'effort pour
redresser ses comptes j'espère que nous
aurons une bonne note et que nous
passerons mais
ça reste il y a toujours un élément
d'aléa évident
violence à l'endroit des journalistes
situation évidemment extrêmement
préoccupante
nous avons par exemple alors je prends
les terrains de guerre nous avons
maintenant 35 journalistes en
continuation sur le terrain ukrainien
depuis le début du conflit
nous avons des dépenses de sécurité qui
sont folles je dirais ça c'est normal
beaucoup plus préoccupant dans un
certain nombre de pays qui n'étaient qui
nous y avait pas habitué nous
journalistes sont régulièrement agressés
à commencer par notre pays où nous avons
eu des cas d'agression caractérisés dans
des manifestations et aujourd'hui quand
vous voyez vous êtes à l'AFP vous voyez
des vidéastes
surtout des vidéastes qui sont des
cibles assez faciles ils ont du matériel
lourd qui qui partent ils sont habillés
comme des Tortues Ninja des vraies
protections je vous assure des
genouillères des casques des des
protections sur les bras partout et avec
un conseiller de sécurité qui les
accompagne parce que leur quand ils
quantifine il voit pas ce qui se passe
autour c'est ça la réalité du métier
aujourd'hui c'est désolant
les droits voisins
comme vous le savez
c'est le c'est pas par mauvaise volonté
qu'on ne communique pas les chiffres
mais par prudence parce que c'est une
clause de résiliation du contrat
que de donner les chiffres donc je ne
les donnerai pas même sous la torture ça
a été une bonne négociation
sinon on aurait pas signé vous
m'interrogez sur les relations avec la
Fédération française des agences de
presse nous avons mené le combat
au nom de l'AFP parce que la Fédération
n'avait pas les moyens de l'action en
justice qui nous a quand même coûté très
cher mais bien entendu elle en a profité
par la suite puisqu'elle a signé elle
aussi un accord avec Google donc on a
j'ai l'impression que on est tous
solidaires et que on a on a tracé la
voie pour après où en sont les relations
avec les autres plateformes aujourd'hui
nulle part ce qui est un problème et
donc on discute on a deux types de
discussion une qui est toujours en face
à face avec meta et l'autre avec les
autres plateformes où on passe par
l'organisme présidé par Jean-Marie
Cavada le DVP où là aussi ça n'avance
pas
donc
pourquoi parce que je pense que la tout
simplement il y a plusieurs choses et
qui peuvent être je pense que c'est bien
le cadre ici pour vous suggérer quelques
pistes si d'aventure il était possible
d'améliorer un jour le texte de loi il y
a un premier problème qui est spécifique
aux agences de presse c'est que il y a
toujours ce débat qui a été tranché par
l'Autorité de la concurrence mais que
les plateformes que Google a accepté
puisqu'il a signé mais que les
plateformes les autres plateformes
aujourd'hui
continuent de réfuter en gros elle
disent nous on est près de rémunérer les
trois voisins pour les contenus d'agence
qui sont qu'on reçoit dit qui sont
fournis directement mais si ça passe par
un éditeur à ce moment-là c'est plus
possible
nous on passe toujours par des éditeurs
de presse pour diffuser nos contenus on
n'a pas d'action B2C alors il y a des
pays où certaines agences ont une
présence bitoussi mais en italien en
particulier mais en France c'est pas le
cas donc ça voudrait dire que la loi
n'avait aucun sens donc il faudrait
clarifier ce point d'autant que
l'Autorité de la Concurrence a tranché
ça c'est le premier point deuxième point
vous avez dans les clauses qu'on appelle
les conditions générales de vente des
plateformes souvent des clauses qui
disent que on sait de nos droits voisins
gratuitement
donc ça c'est une entorse à la loi
évidente et tout ça c'est fait soit ça a
été fait dans le passé et puis
l'habitude a fait que on considère que
c'était la règle intrangée soit c'était
c'est à l'issue d'un rapport de force en
tracteur extrêmement inégaux bon on
finit par signer parce qu'on n'a pas le
choix mais ça il faudrait que la loi
l'interdise parce que c'est tout
simplement contraire à l'esprit à la
lettre de la loi et puis et puis dernier
point je pense que il n'y a pas assez de
mécanismes de d'astre et de qui pousse à
l'action
je pense qu'on pourrait envisager en
gros il faudrait que ça aille plus vite
voilà parce qu'aujourd'hui ça fait quoi
deux ans et demi que la loi était votée
et c'est pas normal qu'on en soit encore
là il faudrait qu'il y ait par exemple
la loi prévoit la publication d'un
certain nombre de données il faudrait
que il y a des astreintes au profit des
des demandeurs si ces données ne sont
pas fournies il faudrait que on puisse
avoir objectiver un peu la négociation
donnée des éléments avec par exemple des
barèmes en termes de page Vue de postes
etc donc ça ce serait bien et puis à la
fin se dire comme c'est le cas comme
vous le savez dans le dans certaines
législations nationales prévoir
l'intervention d'une commission
d'arbitrage si les négociations
n'avancent pas voilà donc la loi
française a été
précurseur on a pu signer un accord très
satisé faisant avec Google et d'ailleurs
nos relations avec Google sont
excellentes et c'est un plaisir voyez
donc c'est possible et je pense que eux
ils ont intégré cette idée que les
droits voisins c'était une réalité et
que c'était
qu'il fallait qu'il fallait avancer on
n'y est pas avec les autres plateformes
et je pense que dans le dispositif
législatif si il était possible à un
moment de le revoir il y aurait je
pourrais faire des faire des suggestions
si vous voulez accepter
[Musique]
sur le fac checking sur le fact checking
donc ça a été
à développement
moi quand je me suis présenté à l'AFP en
2018 je n'avais pas ça dans mon
programme
euros surprise en mai donc un mois après
mon arrivée rendez-vous avec facebook
qui qui demande si on serait prêt à se
lancer à créer des postes de fact
checker et on a on y a cru et on a
développé ce réseau et donc c'est je le
redis et je pense que c'est important
que la représentation nationale est bien
en tête on a le réseau le plus important
au monde et de très très loin
on a 150 factes shakers c'est à dire des
journalistes qui à temps plein dans 80
pays en 24 langues parce qu'on travaille
dans les langues de la désinformation
donc on travaille en philippin on
travaille en hongrois au travail en
indonésien qui regarde ce qui se passe
sur Facebook sur Tik Tok sur Twitter et
qui font un travail d'enquête alors ça
peut faire deux heures de travail
Zelenski arbore un t-shirt avec une
croix gammée vous allez montrer en deux
heures que ça a été photoshopé encore
faut-il le montrer
en revanche
massacre de bout de chat les Russes
disent les images qui ont été prises par
l'AFP sont en fait une mise en scène ce
sont des acteurs et bien vous devez
avoir des équipes qui vont aller
documenter sur le terrain la scène en
expliquant que c'est pas des acteurs
mais des gens du coin dont on a retrouvé
la famille et puis vous avez dans les
bureaux à Londres à Varsovie des facts
qui disent ah les Russes disent que ce
sont des acteurs qui ont été amenés la
veille de la prise des images en fait on
a regardé les images satellites les
corps étaient déjà là il y a 15 jours à
les Russes disent que la preuve que ce
sont des acteurs c'est qu'il y a une
main qui bouge
dans le rétroviseur de l'image mais en
fait quand on décompose la scène on voit
que c'est pas une main qui bouge c'est
juste un effet d'optique parce qu'il y a
une goutte d'eau qui coule voilà c'est
ça le boulot
c'est alors vous dites c'est il y a
effectivement la critique c'est une
goutte d'eau dans l'océan ou bien oui
c'est vider l'océan avec une cuillère
moi là dessus d'abord c'était vrai il y
a évidemment au démarrage aujourd'hui on
a atteint une masse critique on fait 400
facs par mois
l'AFP sol l'AFP n'est pas seul à faire
du fakecking vous multipliez ça il y a à
peu près 250 d'organismes de fac
checking dans le monde ce sont des
médias où ce sont des organismes
spécialisés vous multipliez tout le
monde ne fait pas 400 fake mais vous
multipliez vous avez 9 critique sur la
covid ou sur l'Ukraine vous n'avez pas
une seule fake news importantes virales
qui n'est pas été vérifiée donc c'est un
c'est on peut plus dire ça je pense pour
ceux qui ont qui ont le qui veulent
s'informer qui ont le la curiosité
ils peuvent trouver cette information il
la trouve directement sur les réseaux
sociaux et moi je dis c'est le la
première lame de la ripote c'est pas la
réponse miracle la désinformation mais
si vous n'avez pas ça vous ne pouvez
rien construire derrière mais ça c'est
la première manière de rétablir l'effet
et ça c'est le boulot qui est fait au
quotidien vous dites Tik Tok
[Musique]
a un contrat avec l'AFP je confirme
on a le problème c'est de on a développé
ce courant la difficulté de la relation
avec les plateformes c'est de la
difficulté d'abord un dialogue
stratégique avec elle aujourd'hui parce
qu'elle vous avait souvent des
interlocuteurs assez juniors qui varient
d'une région à l'autre qui change
énormément alors en ce moment avec les
licenciements dans latex c'est très
difficile et c'est très difficile on a
on avait on a construit avec facebook un
vrai partenariat mais là aussi vous dire
que pour les plateformes c'est leur
priorité aujourd'hui malheureusement non
alors j'espère qu'avec le DSA ils vont
se rendre compte que ça doit le devenir
moi ce qui me rend optimiste dans la
durée c'est que les plateformes
vont être tenus d'agir d'abord par par
la régulation et le DSA va être
important mais aussi par pour deux
raisons
fondamentales la première c'est la
pression des salariés sur les
plateformes
parce que les employés de la tech qui
sont des jeunes ingénieurs
ne veulent plus accepter un certain
nombre de pratiques ne veulent plus
travailler chez des employeurs pourris
disons-le comme ça et il y a le sujet de
la réputation employeur devient majeur
et va pousser les patrons de ces de ces
plateformes à agir et le deuxième
alors Twitter je pense que
si Twitter se rétablit
ils vont avoir beaucoup de mal à
recruter après tout ce qui s'est passé
la manière dont ils ont traité leur
personnel je pense que ça va être
extrêmement difficile et c'est une bonne
leçon
je leur souhaite de se rétablir ce
serait très utile pour l'AFP mais
la manière dont ils ont d'abord traité
très traiter leur personnel et ensuite
traiter à la légère du sujet du
frisbeech mais n'est pas de bonne augure
le deuxième facteur de pression c'est
les c'est les c'est les annonceurs et
puisque vous parlez de Twitter Twitter a
perdu 40% de ses recettes publicitaires
en quelques mois pourquoi parce qu'ils
étaient laxistes sur sur le sur le sur
le la désinformation et les annonceurs
ne veulent plus être associés à des
actions néfastes donc sur le fond je
pense que ce sont deux facteurs très
encourageants
dernière dernier point sur le
développement de la vidéo donc nous
produisons aujourd'hui
que je me trompe pas dans mes chiffres
on produit à peu près par jour sans
sujet vidéo différents
dont 32 40 directs ça c'est la grande
nouveauté de ces derniers temps l'AFP
c'est le direct donc beaucoup des
reportages que vous voyez à la
télévision ils sont jamais crédité FP
mais bon surtout si c'est dans des pays
lointains je prends l'exemple de du
tremblement de terre en Syrie Turquie
les images qui ont circulé tant sur les
sites de presse que à la BBC ou autre
c'était des images AFP et je reviens sur
les forces de l'AFP pourquoi des images
de l'AFP mais parce que on a un réseau
un réseau de malades on est les seuls à
avoir gardé un bureau ouvert à Damas
donc quand tu es ultrament de terre nos
équipes sont allées très vitales on est
les seuls à avoir gardé et continuer
d'entretenir un réseau de pigistes dans
le nord de la Syrie qui était une zone
rebelle et donc comme on a gardé ses
liens et ben je peux vous dire ils ont
tout de suite été sur le terrain on a un
opiges qui a perdu 11 personnes de sa
famille dans le tremblement de terre il
était là à tourner des images dans sa
ville et c'est ces images qui ont qui
ont qui ont circulé on a été les seuls à
fournir une image avec un des images
avec un drone on a fait un live vidéo
dès le les premières heures du
tremblement de terre et je vais vous
dire c'est ça l'a fait c'est pour ça
qu'on est retenu c'est parce que on est
les seuls à être présent là où les
autres ne vont plus
ne vont pas ou vont beaucoup moins
qu'avant et ça vous avez cette situation
je prends cet exemple d'une région un
peu oubliée
j'aurais pu vous prendre l'exemple de
l'Éthiopie on a été les premiers à
entrer au tigré pourquoi parce qu'on a
un bureau avec 4,5 personnes à 10 Abba
qui ont les sources qui savent comment y
aller donc c'est pas des correspondants
aujourd'hui dans une région à haute
sensibilité géopolitique comme les
Balkans je pense qu'on est la seule
agence à avoir vraiment du monde sur le
terrain voilà donc c'est ça l'AFP et
c'est pour ça que les clients prennent
nos vidéos c'est parce pour la variété
et la diversité des sujets traités
notamment dans les coins oubliés de la
planète
alors je vais je vais prendre toutes vos
questions en commençant par Monique de
Marco
merci je vous remercie pour toutes ces
explications
je reviens sur un sujet qui a déjà été
abordé cela concerne l'influence voir la
manipulation sur les réseaux sociaux
notamment avec WhatsApp vous avez pas le
loi de chat et on a vu le rôle qu'ils
ont eu pour
l'élection donc de la campagne
électorale au Brésil
quelle forme prend cette coopération et
quels moyens l'agence est susceptible de
mettre en place en période électorale
pour prévenir ce genre de manipulation
et par exemple avez-vous en France une
relation justement par la période
électorale avec le CSA
j'ai une autre question je serai là
peut-être la seule à la poser alors ce
que je prévois des questions
supplémentaires mais celle-ci je pense
que
je suis la seule à poser selon
l'Observatoire développé par
l'association Kota climat seulement 3,6%
des contenus médiatiques pendant la
campagne présidentielle de 2022 porté
sur des questions climatiques entre près
de 75% de temps d'antenne pour le covid
19 dans une tribune de 2021 publiée par
le JDD vous établissiez un parallèle
entre la lutte contre le réchauffement
climatique et la lutte contre la
désinformation la semaine dernière le
ministre Christophe Béchu
s'est fondé sur l'hypothèse nuance de
plus de 4 degrés en France d'ici la fin
du siècle or la lutte pour contre le
réchauffement climatique nécessite une
information de qualité pour faire
accepter à la population les changements
structurels nécessaires dans le futur
comment pensez-vous qu'il faut améliorer
la diffusion de l'information de qualité
en matière environnementale
[Musique]
genre
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
pour cette vision claire et
nette
mes collègues ont posé des questions
très précises sur le cœur du sujet vous
me permettrait de poser des questions un
petit peu connexes il y a un point sur
lequel je ne suis pas d'accord avec ce
que vous avez exprimé c'est quand vous
dites je ne suis pas le mieux placé pour
donner des cours de management
tout dans votre parcours indique le
contraire le nombre de fous
contraire à mon sens voilà et le nombre
de fois vous avez employé le mot
stratégique et particulièrement
important il est au cœur de de votre
action alors juste les deux questions
sont très simples c'est
comment pouvez-vous analyser que
l'audiovisuel public français a autant
de mal à organiser à la fois
l'adaptation et le voilà l'évolution
dans les nouvelles pratiques comme vous
l'avez fait à la tête de l'AFP comme
vous le faites encore à la tête de l'AFP
et puis vous avez je crois en juin 2019
rencontrer quelqu'un qui est au centre
de toutes les questions aujourd'hui qui
s'appelle Vladimir Poutine avec des
collègues des agences des plus grandes
agences du monde
qu'on avait vous retiré voilà et
qu'est-ce que vous avez senti à ce
moment là
TV Robert
merci monsieur le Président moi aussi je
vous adresse toutes mes félicitations et
vous dire que notre attachement à une
agence dont la qualité de l'information
sourcée avec des journalistes produits
de la confiance et je trouve que dans le
contexte actuel et après avoir travaillé
avec un certain nombre de mes collègues
sur la commission d'enquête
concentration des médias cette question
de la fabrique de l'information de la
qualité des journalistes du temps et des
moyens consacrés à l'investigation et à
la recherche seront absolument capitaux
aujourd'hui capital dans le contexte
alors c'est vrai que la dernière fois où
vous aviez mis en avant la question de
la vidéo donc l'adaptation aux usages
mais aussi pour capter
d'autres publics pour un moment élargir
aussi l'audience notamment dans la chez
les jeunes générations la lutte contre
la désinformation je vais pas y revenir
puisque on en a déjà parlé et vous nous
dites aujourd'hui voilà demain en termes
de stratégie pour pour une nouvelle
aventure c'est la communication l'agence
je sais plus comment dont vous allez de
toute façon avoir besoin je ne sais plus
comment vous l'avez exprimé donc ça
c'est très intéressant mais vous en avez
dit un peu trop et pas assez
c'est-à-dire qu'à un moment donné quels
sont du coup les priorités que vous
de façon générale bien sûr les grandes
priorités que vous voyez dans dans les
années à venir sur pour l'AFP mais
globalement dans le contexte de la
presse aujourd'hui et le contexte
international que nous vivons donc ça
c'est ma première question et la
deuxième est-ce que des réflexions qui
sont extrêmement importantes aussi pour
notre société pour souciter démocratique
sur l'intelligence artificielle le méta
vert toutes ces technologies qui
arrivent que l'on voit d'ailleurs
forcément arriver dans un certain nombre
de de secteur de notre société qui vont
d'ailleurs complexifier et compliqués le
travail d'un certain nombre de
professionnels pas seulement de la
formation mais je pense aux chercheurs
je pense aux artistes parce que là j'ai
eu des comment est-ce que vous
appréhendez ces évolutions là est-ce que
ce sont aussi des sujets que vous allez
aborder pour votre prochain mandat merci
beaucoup Nathalie Delattre
merci président tous mes collègues ayant
posé les questions essentielles je
prends la parole d'abord parce que je
voulais aussi vous féliciter pour votre
reconduction méritée et une question
mineure le 5 novembre dernier j'étais en
ligne avec le cabinet Ader vous avez
fait une vente aux enchères de 200
photographies iconiques c'était vraiment
une très belle opération je pense que
une très belle image aussi grand public
mais est-ce que vous avez vendu toutes
les photos est-ce que c'est une
opération bénéfique pour vous est-ce que
vous avez couvert les frais parce que
moi j'ai pu acheter une des photos
c'était Noël peu de temps après donc
j'ai fait un très beau cadeau grâce à
vous et grâce à tes à cette opération
est comptez vous continuez ou poursuivre
ce type d'opération parce que je pense
que c'est une très très belle vitrine
aussi pour pour l'AFP
merci président félicitations également
monsieur le Président d'héritage général
je crois que c'est important que mes
collègues insistent là dessus parce que
ça montrera peut-être aussi à l'état mon
excellent collègue Michel logier me
disait que c'était participation de
l'État de 40 millions d'euros
40 140 millions d'euros j'ai envoyé que
j'étais 140 millions d'euros donc qui
rectifié et la raison et la raison de le
faire parce que je sais que il connaît
bien les chiffres il est très investi au
sein de l'AFP simplement vous avez dit
vous voulez faire que on ne puisse plus
passer de l'AFP dans le monde je crois
que c'est un défi majeur et c'est
important de le dire c'est une prise de
risque l'État participe mais bon il y a
d'autres partenaires bien sûr donc ils
participent la vidéo à mon avis vous
ayez raison de prendre ces virages parce
que vous l'avez fort bien exprimé tout à
l'heure sur l'intérêt mondial vis-à-vis
de cela c'est une prise de risque est-ce
que cette prise de risque est mesurée
est-ce qu'elle est nécessaire c'est ma
première question deuxième point c'est
sur
artificielle vis-à-vis du programme
européen donc qui verra est-ce que vous
pouvez nous donner quelques informations
sur ce projet de septembre 2022 sur
l'utilisation de l'intelligence
artificielle puis enfin lorsque vous
parliez tout à l'heure des checker moi
je me je m'interroge souvent lorsque
vous donnez une information aux médias
les médias je prends juste un exemple
dans une conférence pas une conférence
de presse mais lorsque le minable sur la
formation il a transformé souvent de
positif ou de factuel en négatif exemple
il y a quelques années il y avait
beaucoup de de natalité en France et
c'est terminé au niveau de la formation
comment on fait comment va-t-on faire
pour pouvoir justement garder les
enfants donc ces transformations je ne
sais pas si vous pouvez avoir en tout
cas un rôle par rapport à cela mais la
transformation de ce de cette
information factuelle positive et ne pas
la conduire à quelque chose de négatif
qui arrive sur les médias je vous
remercie
[Musique]
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président merci pour vos propos
introductifs je m'excuse de mon de mon
retard et je serai très brève dans mes
questions et par ailleurs excusez-moi si
vous y avez déjà répondu dans votre
proposéminaire vous évoquez tout à
l'heure à juste titre la très bonne
couverture géographique de l'AFP qui en
fait une force majeure de notre agence
je voulais savoir quels critères vous
mettez en place pour décider que l'AFP
va être présent dans tel ou telle zone
géographique et si en fonction de ces
critères il y a des choix opérés sur les
types d'informations qui ne seront pas
forcément retenus ici cela à un impact
réel sur la couverture de l'information
à l'échelle mondiale et la dernière
question c'est sur les fight checking
est-ce que vous pouvez au regard de ce
que vous remontez de la masse
d'information que vous traitez définir
des tendances lourdes en matière de
factice sur par exemple des thématiques
particulières ou plutôt sur des lieux
d'émanation de cette factice des sources
des pays des groupes d'influence ou des
lobbys voilà je vous remercie
et enfin Jean et Grey
oui merci monsieur le Président Charles
Laurent monsieur le Président Monsieur
une question par rapport lors de votre
propos introductif vous avez signalé qui
avait un contrat qui était en train
d'être signé qui a été signé avec l'AFP
et TikTok moi je suis assez dubitatif
là-dessus quand on connaît les effets
néfastes et négatifs sur la jeunesse
grâce ou à cause de Tik Tok plus
exactement et surtout que certains pays
comme les États-Unis avec l'action du
Sénat américain veulent interdire TikTok
sur le sol national américain qui serait
un outil d'espionnage et des
informations chinois alors je suis quand
même assez étonné que l'AFP qui est une
agence indépendante avec des subventions
d'État puisse envisager un lien avec Tik
Tok je voulais avoir un peu plus de
précision et votre vision sur le lien
que va avoir la SP avec Tik Tok je vous
remercie
le Président je vais vous laisser
répondre toute cette série de questions
les élections et la manipulation je
pense que s'il y a un facteur un peu
d'optimisme sur le dans le débat sur
la désinformation c'est que
les États et les parties prenantes sur
ces sujets des élections ont beaucoup
appris
et tirer les leçons du traumatisme qui a
été l'année 2016 qui a été marqué bien
sûr par l'élection de Trump et par le
brexit ou forte pression de fake news
mais aussi avant même ces deux grands
moments il y avait eu la première
élection Facebook qui était l'élection
de dutterté en 2016 et qui a été
considéré comme le premier moment où les
fake news ont fini par
permettre l'élection d'un président
depuis systématiquement à chaque
élection dans les grands pays là je fais
une aide distinction qui ont les moyens
se forment des coalitions de médias et
d'organisation de fac checking qui
qui font un peu la police des réseaux
sociaux
les États ont aussi beaucoup appris
mettent en place des dispositifs et en
pratique aucune des grandes élections
des dernières années n'a été vraiment
impacté ou comme elle l'avait été en
2016 par par la manipulation les
manipulations de l'information ça existe
bien sûr dans des états plus petits
mais
j'essaye de donner des signes
d'optimisme je pense que on progresse
l'AFP en France puisque vous posez la
question de la France a pris la tête
d'une de ses coalitions
dans une opération qui s'appelait
désintox et qui a été plutôt un succès
et qui a été notamment fait beaucoup
avec la presse quotidienne régionale
qu'on a embarqué
donc on est présent vous avez posé la
question spécifique de WhatsApp et de
WhatsApp au Brésil nous avions nous
avons nous avions une grosse équipe au
Brésil on a beaucoup travaillé avec avec
facebook au Brésil
WhatsApp c'est plus on travaille aussi
avec eux c'est plus compliqué parce que
ce sont des messages cryptés de bout en
bout donc par définition les factures
pour avoir accès au contenu c'est
impossible il faut qu'il vous soit
signalé pour qu'ensuite on puisse faire
ce travail donc ça c'est un des défis de
la lutte contre des informations des
années à venir c'est qu'est-ce que vous
faites sur les plateformes cryptées
WhatsApp mais aussi telegram et beaucoup
d'autres
la question du traitement de la du
climat
alors
concrètement
l'AFP a fait une réorganisation de sa
rédaction
il y a deux ans et
[Musique]
a mis deux sujets en priorité qui était
là ce qu'on appelle la planète les
sujets planètes
[Musique]
et l'autre qui était tous les sujets de
tech comme vous pouvez l'imaginer sur la
planète qu'est-ce que ça veut dire pour
l'AFP pour vous montrer que c'est pas
juste une réforme est
on a plus de services économique à l'AFP
des sujets comme l'agriculture les
transports l'industrie l'énergie sont
traités par les équipes planètes sous ce
prix prisme c'est une révolution
culturelle
évidente donc on s'organise comme tous
les médias ce que je vous dis là
beaucoup de médias vous diraient on met
le paquet là-dessus il faut savoir que
[Musique]
la couverture du climat prend de plus en
plus d'importance dans notre copie comme
dans celle d'autres médias pour autant
l'audience ne suit pas
il y a même un effet je pense qu'on vit
tous individuellement de d'évitement moi
je sais qu'à titre personnel j'ai
beaucoup de mal à lire certains
reportages sur la déforestation en
Papouasie Nouvelle Guinée parce que ça
me déprimait et ces sujets donc sont
souvent curieusement des facteurs
d'abonnement parce que les gens savent
que oui c'est un sujet qui compte mais
c'est difficile un exemple on a envoyé
25 personnes à la dernière cop
on s'est rendu compte que l'utilisation
de nos contenus c'était
ridicule c'est des sujets donc c'est
très difficile alors on progresse il y a
par exemple un facteur de progrès
absolument évident aujourd'hui dans tous
les médias je pense quand vous avez des
images de de canicule quand il y a un
événement de canicule on arrête de
montrer des photos de Fontaine et de
tout le monde des choses qui sont qui
sont lourdes
il y a beaucoup de conférences en ce
moment c'est un peu un marronnier des
conférences
de médias sur ces le climat la
couverture du climat
je pourrais en parler énormément le truc
qui revient le plus souvent c'est quand
on fait du repas faut donner un élément
d'espoir
parce que sinon on plante tout le monde
c'est très difficile
[Musique]
une bonne question sur l'audiovisuel
public français qui aurait du mal à se
transformer
ce sont des clients donc je ne leur veux
que du bien pas par ailleurs je trouve
que
ce sont des
organismes qui sont très bien dirigés
avec des personnes de grande qualité et
je dis pas ça pour être juste diplomate
je pense vraiment et je trouve que ce
sont des boîtes qui sont probablement
plus compliquées à gérer que l'AFP et
qui se sont beaucoup
transformés donc
nous qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire par
rapport à ces
assez il a vraiment vraiment je suis
sincère on a zéro le son à donner
on peut les accompagner les aider à
accompagner à
à conquérir puisque je me souviens que
si bilva il y avait parlé de faire de
Radio France à média de conquête
conquérir un public jeune et un public
qui n'a plus l'habitude de venir alors
pour nous ça veut dire trouver les bons
sujets qui vont qui vont intéresser ce
public jeune planète la tech tous ces
sujets en font partie trouveraient aussi
les bons formats
il est évident qu'aujourd'hui la clé
d'entrée dans la formation pour les
jeunes c'est c'est l'image et donc et
c'est la consultation sur le mobile donc
nous on s'est mis à produire des ce
qu'on appelle des stories qui sont des
vidéos d'information avec beaucoup de
mise en contexte sur des formats
verticaux que vous consultez sur votre
smartphone avec le sous-titre comme on
le fait sur
pour épouser les pratiques du moment
c'est comme ça qu'on peut accompagner
c'est une question existentielle pour
nous aussi parce que si les médias
perdent leur lectorat
au fur et à mesure notre notre utilité
va aussi
être réduite la réunion avec Poutine
j'en ai même fait deux j'en ai c'est un
espèce de rituel qui m'a beaucoup
surpris qui existe depuis une quinzaine
d'années chaque année Poutine fait venir
des patrons les patrons d'agence de
presse c'est assez curieux parce que moi
je suis pas journaliste ça m'arrive
jamais d'interviewer quelqu'un je suis
c'est pas mon métier mais lui considère
que si vous êtes patron d'une agence de
presse vous devez l'interviewer et c'est
c'est un exercice alors je me suis posé
évidemment la question d'y aller en 2000
même en 2019 et en fait c'est la
pression collective parce que tout le
monde y va retard sa société de presse
toutes les agences européennes et tout
le monde qui va bon je me dis pourquoi
c'est distinguer et aussi parce que nous
on a un bureau à Moscou et que j'ai tout
simplement peur que si j'y vais pas il y
aura des représailles j'ai besoin
d'avoir j'ai 30 personnes à Moscou et
et et et alors on pose des questions en
ce moment on a 20 personnes
on a on a on pose des questions
extrêmement dérangeantes vraiment les
questions c'était moi j'avais posé la
question sur l'opposant biélorus qui
avait été il a réponse à tout voilà donc
c'est ce que je peux vous dire
l'impression qu'il me fait c'est
quelqu'un qui est extrêmement rodé qui a
une dialectique très rodée donc c'est un
exercice qui est pas plaisant auquel on
s'est prêté
l'agence tasse a été suspendu de
l'Association européenne des agences de
presse on fait tout ce qu'il faut pour
et nous on soutient énormément l'agent
ukrainienne on a même répondu à des
appels d'offres en leur nom pour qu'ils
puissent l'emporter et et avoir un peu
de courant de business
comment devenir l'agence préférée des
médias il y a effectivement on va devoir
dérouler un plan
pour moi les je vous donne juste les
têtes de chapitre
notre force et le réseau de terrain on
avait il faut il faut qu'un média puisse
en confiance n'avoir que l'AFP et donc
ne pas louper de grands événements il y
avait géographiquement une zone où on
était moins bon que les autres c'était
les États-Unis on s'est énormément
renforcé ces cinq dernières années et
donc en pratique pendant la dernière
élection dans la soirée électorale on
avait des vidéastes dans 32 villes donc
on a mis le paquet on a passé aussi des
accords de distribution de contenu parce
qu'on prétend pas être partout il y a
des trucs qu'on suit pas par exemple les
sports américains on les suit pas donc
on a des partenariats en photo avec
Getty avec ABC donc il s'agit pas de
prétendre tout couvrir mais il faut
enfin ses propres moyens mais il faut
nouer ses partenariats curieusement il y
a un pays et je rejoins peut-être la
question sur les sur les zones
géographiques
on a on a comme mission c'est dans nos
statuts de fournir une formation
complète donc il est pas question pour
nous délaisser une région alors que nos
concurrents le font la société de presse
a énormément réduit son réseau et se
concentre dans les villes qui sont
importantes pour ses clients américains
nous on a on est on est on est présent
absolument partout c'est
et pour c'est pour cela qu'on reçoit une
aide d'État au passage
curieusement une des régions où on veut
se renforcer c'est un peu contradictif
c'est l'Afrique parce qu'on est déjà
bien supérieur à la société de presse et
même à Rethel dans cette région mais les
clients souvent nous prennent
précisément notamment la BBC nous nous a
pris il y a quatre ans c'était Manuela
qui avait signé l'accord parce que on
était très fort en Afrique et donc il
s'attend à ce qu'on soit
particulièrement bon et comme on a
plutôt mille paquets de ces derniers
temps sur les régions le témoin bon là
on doit se renforcer ça c'est la
couverture géographique être fournir des
enfin donner l'assurance qu'on fournira
des sujets surtout quoi deuxième
c'est
deuxième chose c'est au plan commercial
avoir une offre qui soit adaptée aux
besoins de nos clients par exemple on a
développé pour les petits clients une
offre modulaire où ils peuvent acheter
ce qu'on appelle des packs de crédit ils
sont pas obligés de s'abonner au 5000
dépêche quotidiennes l'AFP ou 3000
photos etc donc ils n'ont ils n'ont pas
ils ont même pas les ressources pour
gérer ça ils peuvent acheter un pack de
250 photos dans l'année et on développe
beaucoup de de
courant d'affaires en ce moment en
Afrique et au Moyen-Orient grâce à cette
nouvelle offre
et puis c'est dans la qualité de la
relation commerciale c'est dans les
outils technologiques qu'on utilise de
livraison par exemple on a beaucoup
investi dans une nouvelle plateforme de
présentation de enfin tout ça pour pour
faire en sorte qu'on soit au meilleur
standard du marché et qu'on soit
l'évidence l'agence qui est le plus
proche de nos clients parce que souvent
quand on est pris par par un média on
nous dit que la raison c'est parce que
on a cette couverture de terrain qui est
extrêmement variée mais aussi parce que
la relation client est bonne donc c'est
bon à savoir il faut le développer le
poids de l'intelligence artificielle
alors évidemment
c'est un des grands sujets du moment
pour nous l'intelligence artificielle
c'est un outil de productivité pour le
journaliste pour l'automatisation des
tâches éditoriales les plus répétitives
dès lors aussi que vous avez à traiter
d'une d'un grand volume de données donc
c'est des applications extrêmement
concrètes je vous donne juste les têtes
de chapitre pour nous c'est tout ce qui
est logiciel qu'on appelle speech to Tex
bah vous interview le président Lafont
et tout de suite le texte sort sans que
j'ai à tout retapé je l'interview pas
parce que je ne suis pas journaliste et
qui n'est pas monsieur Poutine donc j'ai
pas besoin de le faire mais
voilà
tout ce qui tous ceux qui est
reconnaissant faciale je vous donne un
exemple qu'on a utilisé ce week-end lors
des Grammies Awards à Los Angeles
on a une base de données avec tous les
acteurs et donc dès qu'il y a un tapis
rouge avec une photo vous avez souvent
4,5 acteurs qui sont pas toujours les
plus connus bah toc ce qu'on appelle les
métadonnées donc la légende etc apparaît
absolument impeccable pour la Coupe du
monde même chose le joueur le truc tout
ce la reconnaissance des objets tout ce
qui est indexation par exemple des
citations un journaliste veut retrouver
la citation exacte du président Lafont
il y a 10 ans sur le sujet tac ça sort
donc ça c'est des outils de productivité
qui sont très utiles et puis il y a tout
le sujet de la lutte contre les fake
news aujourd'hui évidemment avec les les
nouveaux outils il y a une course de
vitesse entre les propagateurs de fake
news et les et ceux qui les acteurs de
la lutte et tout ça se fait à base
d'intelligence artificielle donc on
investit naturellement dans ce domaine
en essayant de cibler nous on n'est pas
des on n'est pas des acteurs de la
technologie il faut trouver les bonnes
les bons partenaires
la vente aux enchères c'était la seconde
qu'on faisait
et nous avons vendu pour 150000 euros on
a pas tout vendu mais probablement 90%,
c'est
vous dire que c'est une opération
rentable serait très exagérée on rentre
dans nos frais c'est un outil de
communication et de valorisation du fond
parce que cet argent sert à numériser
notre fond l'AFP dans ces cas va des
trésors figurez-vous qu'on a des plaques
de verre avec des photos de la guerre
d'Espagne
qui sont absolument extraordinaires et
inexploitées donc on utilise cet argent
pour faire ça et on va continuer et on
va faire des expositions thématiques on
en fait une rencontre d'Arles
prochainement sur la libération de Paris
là on a un fond extraordinaire qui est
bon et donc on a c'est la deuxième année
c'est plutôt un succès à beau succès
populaire puisque on a eu beaucoup de
visiteurs c'est bien pour l'image de
l'AFP
l'information positive c'est un des
grands là aussi marronniers des
conférences médias comment faire en
sorte que d'éviter de déprimer tout le
monde c'est difficile je dis pas qu'on a
la recette
mais il y a cette prise de conscience
que les notamment les jeunes
cherchent beaucoup de mises en contexte
et de journalistes qu'on appelle le
journaliste de solution alors vous avez
des des médias qui se spécialisent là
dedans moi je rappelle que nous on est
on n'est pas là pour nous on est là pour
raconter ce qui se passe et d'essayer
d'être aussi exact et impérial impartial
que possible on fait pas d'éditorial
donc on n'est pas là pour enjoliver une
un fait
les tendances lourdes de la
désinformation les thématiques les lieux
les thématiques c'est pas compliqué
c'est tout ce qui divise puisque les
États qui sont derrière la
désinformation
veulent
avant tout diviser et donc c'est tous
les sujets clivant c'est genre religions
migration
séparatisme voilà c'est les sujets
ensuite les lieux c'est global c'est pas
compliqué et nous c'est une des raisons
d'ailleurs pour lesquelles ce réseau est
une force et que la raison pour laquelle
on est on a cette position c'est qu'on a
un réseau géographique extrêmement tendu
et que les fake news se baladent d'une
région à l'autre vous avez une histoire
de migrants il y a un exemple qui est
très connu d'une on voit une vidéo d'un
migrant entre guillemets qui frappe une
infirmière dans un hôpital en Australie
elle voyage deux mois après vous la
retrouvez dans les Balkans et elle finit
aux Etats-Unis et à chaque fois le
migrant c'est juste son identité qui
change donc ça se balade donc il y a pas
de lieux privilégiés il y a c'est un
phénomène massif et global
Tik Tok
j'ai envie de dire que si on le fait pas
nous on sera au travail avec tous les
médias on se demande pas si c'est des
médias sympa ou non
parce que là on entre dans des comptes
on entre dans des considérations
politiques
sans fin donc
heureusement qu'on Facebook quand même
je dis pas que c'est la solution au
problème mais heureusement qu'on le fait
et on travaille avec beaucoup d'acteurs
qui sont qui sont parfois désorganismes
de propagande vous avez on a des dans
des régimes autoritaires on a des
clients donc
il rendra à ça
deux dernières questions des camarades
de Damien et Michel legier
en commençant par Damien peut-être c'est
la référence il m'a donné des idées
c'est pour ça je
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président je suis Damien c'est français
établir de France et vous venez après un
peu plus d'une heure de mentionner le
mot qui était l'objet de ma question
l'Afrique en particulier ma question
concerne l'Afrique subsaharienne
le président Macron a justifié en partie
ça réforme du Quai d'Orsay par l'absence
de et l'incompétence je mets des
guillemets de nos diplomates sur la
communication
aujourd'hui enfin plutôt avant-hier le
Mali hier la République centrafricaine
aujourd'hui Burkina Faso on a peu
d'informations dans les médias sur ces
sur ces situations et ces pays on a à
faire face à la Russie la Chine la
Turquie pour nos cité que ces trois là
est-ce que vous pensez que d'abord
est-ce que vous avez les moyens
nécessaires est-ce que vous jugez que
vous avez les moyens nécessaires la
possibilité de travailler dans ces pays
et ce qu'on a une chance de gagner cette
guerre d'influence aujourd'hui
sur cette zone qui est particulièrement
sensible merci
Michel juste un sujet qui est vraiment
en pleine d'actualité
quel est l'impact des Jeux Olympiques
sur l'activité de l'agence France Presse
sur 2023 et surtout sur 2024
je commence par cette dernière question
c'est un c'est un coup c'est pas une
source de revenus ou marginalement
puisque nos fonctionnons sur un système
d'abonnement donc qui est un événement
particulier ou pas en termes de revenus
on vendra peut-être un peu plus de ce
qu'on appelle des photos à la pièce mais
c'est surtout des coûts à la Coupe du
Monde au
Qatar on avait 150 personnes sur place
je dis ça parce que souvent quand je dis
on avait les gens disent 150
la raison c'est qu'on fait texte photo
vidéo et on travaille en silence donc ça
va vite alors c'était 150 la première
semaine quand il y avait toutes les
équipes après le dispositif se vide puis
on a beaucoup de techniciens pour
assurer la diffusion en temps et en
heure des équipes qui installent les
robots sur les toits etc donc c'est des
coûts
ce qui veut dire que ni la Coupe du
monde de rugby ni les Jeux olympiques de
2024 ne vont ne vont changer la face de
l'AFP en termes de revenus ça va être en
revanche ça va ça va être des sources de
dépenses la question sur l'Afrique et
notamment la zone donc je vous disais en
Afrique on est on est l'agence qui a des
trois le plus gros réseau on a des
difficultés évidemment de travailler
dans certains pays je pense
particulièrement Mali
on a beaucoup de pression sur nos
journalistes on représente quand même un
peu on n'est pas la voie de la France je
le précise mais on a il y a quand même
un drapeau français quelque part donc on
est très souvent la cible des trolls et
des actions de rétorsion
des gouvernements
[Musique]
donc on couvre on a fait des très très
beaux sujets y compris des sujets de
magazine sur les peaux etc en couvre
autant qu'on peut on a renforcé le
dispositif on vient de créer deux postes
de vidéastes Lagos et à Dakar enfin on
se c'est vraiment comme je disais une
priorité après c'est une lutte inégale
[Musique]
parce que là je parle de la de ce que
peut faire le gouvernement français en
matière de de lutte contre des
informations parce qu'il n'agissent pas
avec les mêmes armes que Wagner et bien
d'autres et heureusement il y a des
choses qui peuvent pas se permettre il y
a des règles donc c'est une c'est un
combat inégal notre rôle là-dedans
on a fait une réunion avec le Quai
d'Orsay qui souvent nous a sollicité
pour qu'on pour qu'on fasse un fake sur
tel et tel dossier et on a expliqué
pourquoi parfois on ne pouvait pas
répondre parce que très souvent je
prends un exemple dont je me souviens
c'était je pense dans un bout de choses
Burkina Faso
le il était dit que le président
chassé s'était réfugié à l'ambassade de
France et lequel nous a dit fait un fake
pour dire que c'est pas vrai nous on a
répondu on veut bien mais il faut qu'on
ait au moins deux sources qui qui
démontent on les avait pas il faut et
puis il y a parfois on ne sait pas nous
on est extrêmement surveillés par toute
la communauté des complotistes on doit
faire très attention à ce qu'on raconte
et souvent on dit on ne sait pas quand
on fait un fake c'est pas toujours on
n'a pas l'arrogance de dire on sait on
dit voilà ce qu'on sait
et souvent on ne sait pas donc on sait
ce qu'on a expliqué ok on peut bien sûr
on est à l'écoute on n'est pas la voix
de la France donc on est complètement
indépendant et il y a des cas très
nombreux on dit on ne peut pas parce que
c'est notre image de qualité éditoriale
d'indépendance qui est en jeu et si on
ne sait pas on le fera pas voilà donc
plus généralement
évidemment après majeur et un combat
très inégal pour des raisons qu'on peut
comprendre et donc ça passe par d'autres
actions qui sont absolument pas de mon
ressort de de
promotion de ce que
de ce que peut faire la France dans
cette région mais ça c'est un tout autre
sujet
merci monsieur le Président pour ces
réponses très précises à nos questions
vous avez vu l'attachement de la
commission mais vous le saviez à la FP
et au travail que vous menez avec toutes
vos équipes j'en profite à propos de vos
équipes pour saluer aussi la
correspondante de l'AFP au Sénat
Véronique Martinage qui suit de manière
très continue et précise nos travaux ici
donc je profite de votre présence pour
la saluer également merci beaucoup merci
merci beaucoup